- Morning guys, how's it going?
Hello from afar or virtually.
I know this is weird
but I guess we all have to
get used to it for some time.
My name is Donovan.
I'm a graduate fellow here
at Rockefeller University.
Which is in the upper
East Side in New York.
I hope you guys are warm and cozy at home
because the walk for me,
even though it's 50 degrees outside
I felt it was a bit cold.
A little background about me.
I'm a graduate student.
Originally from Singapore.
I was born and raised in Singapore.
But then I moved to California,
to do my K-12 education.
And then I went to undergrad at Seattle.
So I stayed, I spent most
of my time in the West Coast
and I don't want to get into any arguments
saying it's the best coast
but I'll just leave it at that.
And before I get really get started
I just want to get a sense of everyone.
I know everyone's going to
have to chat with me virtually
or you're welcome to use your mic
or camera if you want.
But just to get a sense
of everyone's here,
give me, just type in a one,
if you're a summer person.
Or two, of you're a winter person.
Okay, I see a lot of...
- [Student] I'm a Winter person.
- Half way, all winter.
Actually this is a half
summer, half winter
which makes sense, which makes sense.
I can see that, I guess in New York.
Okay, you play hockey yeah.
Coming from California,
I'm a summer person.
I don't care if it's humid or muggy.
I like it. I just like it.
I like the hot sun, you know.
So well at least this winter,
you get to enjoy the seasons inside.
All right.
So today I'll be talking
to you guys a little bit
about PCR or Polymerase Chain Reaction.
Something that as a research scientist
almost all of us do all the time.
Whether we like it or we not.
And it's actually super
applicable in all sorts of ways.
And I'll get into that
a little bit at the end.
So what is PCR?
Well, I'll start off with DNA, right?
So DNA is the genetic
material that basically
encodes everything
that is necessary to make
a living organism. Right?
From bacteria to us humans.
And every time we divide,
we have to also divide
and replicate our DNA.
And it turns out that
we're able to take
advantage of this system,
this ability to replicate our DNA
and actually use it for
genetic engineering purposes
or to study specific genes of interest
within your, within your chromosome.
And this is developed in
80's and something now
that we've been doing for decades, right?
And now it's for back then, it used to be,
something that everyone would
spent hours and hours upon.
And now it's like the back of our hands,
how we can do PCR.
So what is PCR?
Okay, I want to just, Oh my, I
guess my screen is backwards,
so I apologize.
But PCR would be Polymerase,
I'm going to read out loud,
Polymerase Chain Reaction.Okay?
Polymerase chain reaction.
So maybe we can break
down these words together,
even though it's backwards.
Polymerase, you can break
down the word polymerase
into basically two
sections, polymer and ase.
So what is a polymer?
"It's only backwards for you."
Oh, okay perfect.
Well, I'm glad.
So what is the polymer, right?
Anyone to give me a guess for polymers.
You guys can google it
if you guys really want.
But I have a hunch you guys know it.
Cause you guys are smart
AP biology students.
No, yes, no.
Maybe, so I can give you guys a hint,
formed by monomers yeah.
- [Student] Combination of monomers.
Yeah. Combination of monomers.
Yeah, so polymer is,
is basically a molecule
that is made out of repetitive units.
Right? And yeah.
Chain of macromolecules, long
repeating chains of molecules.
That's great.
And you guys are right.
A polymer is exactly that,
which is exactly our DNA.
An ase. What is an ase?
Maybe you guys have heard a lot of it
in biology or chemistry.
Any, any one I, enzyme.
Yeah, exactly.
Thanks Chelsea.
Enzyme is ase, ase is an enzyme.
So you think about polymerase
which is an enzyme that's going
to work on a polymer, right.
And happens to be, this
polymers is going to be the
your DNA is an enzyme
that works in your DNA.
There are many types of enzymes,
from like amylase the enzyme
that makes the pretzels taste sweet
in your mouth, right?
And so forth.
And then chain reaction.
So chain reaction is very intuitive
but for polymerase chain reaction
what happens is you're taking your enzyme
that is working on the
DNA, the polymerase.
And you're going to let it react
on the DNA over and over
again, a chain reaction.
Almost like as if you tip
a domino over a chain of dominoes
and they all fall in line, right?
And that's basically what a PCR is.
It's a chain reaction of
your DNA over and over again,
to basically make more
of a gene of interest
or make more of a DNA
sequence of interests.
So this is, this might
not make a lot of sense
by just describing it.
So I'll give you a quick picture,
and then I'll show you guys how it works.
So, for PCR and how it works,
there's three steps, right.
And in my high school
we learned this like horrible song
and I'm not going to teach you guys that
because I myself cannot
get out of my head.
But how it works for PCR
is you have a DNA of interest, right?
And let's say it could be
a DNA that's super long
or it could be super short.
And basically you have a
you have something within the DNA
that you're really really interested in.
But only having one or two
copies of this DNA is not enough.
And that's why you use PCR
to rep, to make maybe 5,000
or 10,000 copies of this DNA.
So you can see more of it.
And basically what happens
is you have your DNA
and a little stroke fragment.
I don't know if you can
see this little pink.
We're going to call this a primer,
basically a short fragment
that resembles just part of the DNA,
but not the whole thing.
And that's something you can
actually chemically synthesize
or buy from company.
And it's very, very cheap to
make small things like this.
And what you're going to do first
is you're going to denature.
So denaturing your DNA fragments
and how we denature it.
Well, let me ask you this.
DNA. See this, this may
be a, a pop question.
Pop quiz question.
DNA is how is, how is DNA kept together?
This may be a chemistry question
but let's see who can pick that up?
How is DNA, how are the two
strands of DNA bound together?
And you guys can guess.
Any guess you want.
Bond, hydrogen bonds, Layla, perfect.
Hydrogen bonds. Wow.
This is faster than how I used
to raise my hand in class.
I feel like I'm getting out smarted here.
So hydrogen bond, right?
So DNA is bound by hydrogen bonds
and hydrogen bonds are these
super high energy bonds,
that take a lot of work
to actually break apart.
And so it's a denature,
what you actually want to do,
is you want to denature your DNA
which is basically
putting really high energy
or heating up really
high to start separating
the two strands of DNA.
Meanwhile, you had this
little primer guys,
little pink guy just hanging out.
Next step is what you would do
is you would anneal your DNA.
So you would anneal your primer to your
to one of the strands of the DNA, right?
And that way they're basically matching.
So instead of matching
with the original piece
which are matching,
you can, you can match
with a smaller piece
because the smaller piece
will always be more likely
to bind than the longer piece.
And then you extend, this
is where you take use
of the polymerase that we talked about.
The polymerase is just this large machine
that basically will bind to a
double stranded piece of DNA.
And in this case
because we have a primer
that you annealed it to,
it will bind to this
double-stranded DNA, right?
This just, just the short fragment
and then extend along
this, this leftover piece
and fill it in.
Right? And then you
repeat, you go back up,
you break it apart and then
you repeat over and over again.
And by doing this, you
actually create more and more
of the same fragment that
you're building right here.
And you get more and more and more DNA.
All right?
And once you get more and more DNA of this
of this specific fragment of interest
you can actually start
using it all sorts of things
whether it's for like studies
or, or even like lab tests.
So rather than talk at you all day long
I'm going to just show you
guys how all of it works.
Yeah. And I can give you guys a tour
of the lab while I'm walking over to it.
So I'm going to use my camera,
and what should happen
is I'm going to switch
from my phone to my, from
my camera to my phone.
Can you see, okay, you guys see me?
Okay, you guys can see me.
Cool. All right.
So I'm going to go, I'm going
to show you how PCR works.
And this is my crib.
Welcome to MTV, my crib, my bench,
and where most of the things happen.
But I'll show you guys what
happens in the PCR reaction.
So PCRs usually happen
and you guys can still hear me, right?
I guess you can still hear me.
So PCRs usually happen in
these small little tubes.
I don't know if you can see it
but they're as tiny as it gets.
They're, you know, they're
smaller than my hand.
And these little tubes,
you can see that there's
the bits of liquid.
Right now they're frozen
but I have some pre-made
already for you guys
that basically are PCR reactions.
And chasing to go through.
This is how a PCR.
This is how a PCR looks
like or on a PCR machine.
It's a big machine that can
fit these little tubes in.
And we can do exactly
what we talked about.
Denature, extend.
Denature, anneal and extend.
So high temperatures you
can denature something.
Now lower temperatures
when you cool it down,
your small little fragment
will anneal to the,
to the main DNA.
And then you can extend for a long time.
That's where the
polymerase will keep going
along the DNA to make more of it.
And then you repeat times 35. Repeat.
And then once you're
done, you're good to go.
And actually, it's nice that
we have a machine like this
but in the 80's and 90's,
they would have a poor
student that would actually
that would actually
stand there in the water
or standing with like three
different buckets of water
at different temperatures
going back and forth.
And that would be their entire PhD.
Now it's, you know
done with within two hours
or three hours by machine.
So it's pretty nice.
Now, let me get a chance to show you guys
the the reaction itself
and how we can actually visualize it.
So, here's is a reaction
I've already made.
I dyed it blue so I can
actually show it to you guys
on the gel.
And then we're going to run it
on a gel, on a gel to actually
see what it looks like.
And it's called gel
electrophoresis. All right?
I'm going to grab the gel real quick
I'll be right back.
Take like one second.
Okay. I'll be right back.
So, this is the DNA gel, as you can see,
it's solid squishy.
And I'm going to take that out.
Here's where I'll try
and switch my cameras
to see if this will work upside down.
You guys see.
All right. You guys can see all this.
Cool.
So this is the machine that I talked about
and I'll go over what this machine is
in a bit, but I'll show you
guys how, how we can run our
run our sample on a DNA gel
and actually visualize
the DNA that you made.
And actually, this is
something that I need
for my own experiments.
So you guys can actually
see something happening
in real time and something
that I care about.
So we can take our sample.
You can see here, I can pipette it.
Put it into these wells.
Did you see that?
Did you guys see these little wells here?
Did you guys see little like,
like light indentations?
That's actually where
the liquid for your DNA
or where your DNA goes in.
That's how it fits into the gel.
And I'll explain how
the gel works in a bit
and I'll make a lot more sense.
So I have two samples, so I'm throwing in.
And then as always,
I'm going to add a ruler
and I'll explain the
ruler in just a second.
All right.
And what I'm doing now actually
is I'm setting up the
machine to run the gel,
to basically run electricity to it,
but I'll go over what gel electrophoresis
is in just a second.
Okay. Okay, cool.
And it's not going to run that long
but we'll just have it running for awhile.
All right. So I'm going to switch back.
All right. So while it's running
and I'll show you guys the gel a bit.
I'll just go over what
gel electrophoresis is.
Yeah, Gel electrophoresis.
Gel electrophoresis,
which is a very long name.
It sounds like a mouthful.
Basically is the idea
that you can run something
through a gel using electricity.
All right.
And this is useful
because you can actually
sort things based on
their electric charge.
All right?
And so let me ask you guys this.
Is DNA negatively or positively charged?
Anyone knows this is maybe
a little bit of negative.
Yeah. Yes Winnie thank you
are negatively charged, yeah.
And because you need it negatively charged
you guys can see that it
will actually run electricity
from this way, down this way.
So from positive down to, or, sorry.
Yeah. From positive down to sorry.
Negative down to positive, right?
Yeah. And basically how it works
is that, sorry I was wrong.
It's it should be, it should
be negative to positive.
I don't know why I said that.
It should be negative to positive.
Negative to positive.
And how it works is that
you have electricity running
from the negative electrode
down to the positive electrode.
Right. And since you said,
since Winnie you said
that DNA is negative,
basically you're going to be
able to sort your DNA by size
by how negatively charged it
is as the DNA gel runs across.
In case, see how it's running down slowly.
It used to be like up there
and I was a little bit lower down.
Right. You guys can see that.
All right. So while it's running,
let me ask you this.
For negative, if um,
for a gel like this,
where will the largest bands show up?
The largest if it might be,
Let's say I have multiple
multiple sizes of DNA.
Will the larger DNA show up
higher or lower on this gel.
If I had a larger piece of DNA
and I was running it on the gel,
and this is sorting by, by
from negative to positive,
sorting by electrical charge.
Where do you guys do
you guys can guess too.
Where do you guys think
that the DNA is going to be.
The larger the DNA the
higher or the lower the gel.
Okay. You got some lower the gel.
The other thinks it's lower the gel.
Todd thinks this it's higher
than the higher and you
guys are hardworking guys.
It's okay. You don't have
to have a right answer.
Higher, lower, higher, lower, higher,
lower, lower, lower, okay,
lower, lower. All right, cool.
We can go over this again.
Yeah. Yeah.
Nice, nice guesses, everyone.
And actually want to tell you
and maybe you guys can guess what,
guess, guess why in your mind.
Actually turns out and you will see later
that the DNA actually is going.
The larger your DNA, the higher
is going to be in the gel.
And that's because we talked
about how it's running
going from negative to positive, right.
And you're running electricity through it.
And so if your DNA gel DNA is
larger, if it's much larger
of a DNA, it means it's going
to be more negatively charged
than smaller pieces of DNA.
And if it's more negatively charged
it's going to have a
lot harder time having
to move its butt over
to the positive side.
Right? So it's going to drag itself
and take a lot longer to go
through the walls,
while smaller pieces of DNA
because it's less negatively charged,
it's going to move much
faster down the gel.
I mean you guys should
actually be able to see this
So I'm going to put this over here.
So it's not going to blind everyone
Turn off the lights.
You guys should be able to see,
how bands are moving along the gel.
Do you guys see that?
Actually fluorescent.
And you see how there's like,
there's like what you
saw the blue dye was,
but right below the blue dye,
you can actually see these bands.
And actually what you're seeing
actually it's pretty cool.
Overtime you're seeing this
whole, all these bands separate.
And Zoom takes some time
and I'll just kind of let it sit here.
You can see how it's separating over time.
Really, really slowly.
This feels like a slow-mo video
but this is just in real life.
And that's kind of how
gel electrophoresis works.
And this is really important for PCR
because well I can see
everything happened in the tube
or, well I can make
everything happen in the tube.
I don't actually know what's inside
until I actually do the,
do the reaction. Right?
And you can actually see it go slowly
and slowly and slowly.
And that's basically how it goes.
And I'm going to just put me
to one last thing to show you
guys what the end result is.
And so I'm going to show you guys,
this will take roughly 20 minutes,
but rather than let you guys sit there
and wait for 20 minutes,
I can actually show you
guys what the end result is.
So give me a second.
And this is what an end
result would look like.
All right.
I just like you guys talked about,
this lower band, that's probably smaller
than the upper band up there.
And now you can tell here look, I made
I made this fragment.
I made this, this little
segment of interest
and now I can take it out to
use it for further studies
or for other stuff, whatever
you guys want. Right?
As you can see, this is like
I feel like a cooking show over here.
This is my before, and
this is my after, right?
It nearly ran for 20 minutes already.
Actually you can even see here
it's already starting to separate.
You can actually see two
bands already, right?
So that's basically how PCR works
and how we can visualize PCR
in lab using gel electrophoresis
in this cool little box.
Actually this blue box is to
filter out the blue light,
but I didn't have it.
You can be blinded by it
Actually I'm blinded by it
right now so I'm not gonna do
that to myself but yeah, that's it.
Oh, there's two faces of
me. Let's not do that.
And that's basically
how gel electrophoresis works in PCR.
Let me take off my gloves
and move back to my bench.
I shall let this run.
So you can see after a
while how it's going.
And I'll come back and talk
to you a little bit more.
Does anyone have any quick questions?
You guys are always welcome to interject
and ask something as it goes.
But that's something that
we do in lab all the time.
To do PCR's and seeing if, you know
we're able to clone out,
take out a specific gene of interest
out of the, out of our, out of
out of the genome of a cell.
Insulin. Insulin is a protein that is.
Is this the only way to separate DNA?
Gel you mean gel electrophoresis?
Gel electrophoresis is not
the only way to separate DNA.
You can actually separate DNA
through like columns as well
which is similar to a gel.
And I don't want to get too much into it
but basically you can sort,
you can also sort something similar to a
rather than a gel.
You can start sorted through a big column
that acts like a gel I guess.
That's when we were separating DNA.
And that's also useful if you
want it to be all in liquid
rather than that thing
is this is a solid gel.
So later on, if I actually
want to take out the DNA
I have to cut the gel out and purify that.
So, yeah, but this is really useful
for genetic engineering, for example.
So one of the, one of the
really important genes in our
in ourselves is insulin.
Our ability to create insulin
and regulate our sugar levels.
And it turns out that, you know
for people who have diabetes,
they actually need insulin.
I think diabetes, diabetes 1
you actually need insulin or diabetes 2
correct me if I'm wrong.
But you actually need insulin given.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to
get to that in a second.
You actually need insulin
given to you from, from
from medical sources.
And people can actually get
people have spent a lot
of time engineering,
taking out the insulin gene from ourselves
and then growing it
in large, E.Coli, large bacteria cultures
and purifying that protein out.
And that's the insulin
that we take or that diabetics take daily.
So that's one way, that's
one application of PCR
that's really important.
Perhaps the one that is most important
to note everyone's mind right
now is, is COVID testing.
Yeah, this is, this is
basically a simplified version
of how we, how we look at or how
how they do do the COVID 19 PCR RNA
or PCR analysis and checking whether
or not you're positive for
the COVID-19 RNA or not.
So in this case, not that case,
I'm going to talk about
just for a little bit,
in that case, they use RNA instead of DNA
but all the methods are
still very similar and
and so forth.
So the boogers that they pick
out of your nose at the end,
they're checking what for, not for
for whether they can see
those trace amounts of, of
of COVID-19 RNA using PCR.
Oh, the gel light turned
off, but it's okay.
Can you use this to check
if two person are related,
like matching DNA?
Yeah. So you can, and this
is so like yes, you can.
So, so you guys have
heard of 23andMe, right?
23and Me and like all
the other, like sort of
or the best product, perhaps
the most like modern or
or like less medically related, you know
sequencing things people talk about.
But yeah, they basically
use a similar method to
to PCR. They use a modified version
of PCR to basically read the DNA sequence,
actually using a very, using
using basically PCR to
read a DNA sequence.
And for people to check
if they're related,
you can basically pull out a fragment.
If you think there's a fragment that only
those two are related with
let's say a mutation or something.
You can use that to check for DNA.
Can you use it to date something?
Can I use it to date something?
You know, you can actually
use it for evolution.
So people, a lot of
people who want to study
how like organisms evolve
or like the, the evolution of
a certain gene, for example
they can look at well, this, you know
they can see how individual amino acids
or individual based pairs mutate over each
each organism over the years or each
over each organism to see
the evolution timeline.
You can use this to date something,
However, I will say that like older,
so a lot of people try to look at the DNA
of like dinosaurs and all that junk.
The older your DNA,
like the old, let's say, as a dinosaur,
like as ancient as it gets
your DNA gets more and more fragmented.
And it becomes a lot harder
to actually PCR something
that is of like, of any
intellectual like worth.
Hannah asked me,
"can we use clonal species
through genetic engineering?"
Yeah. So cloning a whole species
means you have to clone
the entire genome, right?
And I will say that people have,
I don't think they did it by,
I'm not sure if they did a PCR
but people have generated
their own like suit.
Like they made their own genome basically
out of using a bunch of different
I think using yeast, like, you know
Baker's yeast or whatever to
create their own like genome.
And that is basically one way of doing it.
But I don't think anyone has used
as a clone in an entire
species just for, for PCR.
Yeah.
Why is DNA heated to 94 degrees?
I remember about running that temperature.
Right. Right. All right.
So we're going to go back to, yeah.
Why, why do we have to in the
in the first step of PCR where I
denature, denature the DNA
and then anneal and an extend.
Why do I have to heat it to 94 degrees?
Which sounds like it's blazing hot.
So remember when I asked you guys
on how DNA was bonded and you guys
and you guys are all really smart
and said hydrogen bonds,
well it turns out if you, if, if
if you guys kind of
remember from Chemistry,
hydrogen bonds are one of the strongest
like biomolecular bonds and takes a lot
of energy to break something
like a hydrogen bond.
And so you have to heat it
to very high temperatures
to break that bond apart.
Yeah. Covalent bonds, you know
will not break in that temperature.
So your DNA, your DNA won't
break in half like this,
but because these are hydrogen bonds,
those will just fall off.
Yeah. There's a lot of ton
of applications for PCR.
And this is something that
like I do in all the time
thinking about my research.
A little bit when I work,
I study how cells feel, feel forces
just like how you guys, if you guys
when we used to take the
train when it was really busy
and it's not as packed anymore on trains
But when we used to, you
can tell it's really crowded
because you don't need to see
or you don't need to
see that it's crowded.
You can feel everyone
and bumping into you.
Cells can also feel, do the same thing.
They don't need eyes.
They don't have eyes and they
can feel how crowded it is.
And we're interested in understanding
how do cells feel forces
or feel each other anyways.
But yeah, I do this.
I use PCR in my, in my
experiments all the time.
And it's really helpful
for genetic engineering
like people are talking about and you know
something that people talk
about a lot is CRISPR.
Maybe you guys have heard
about CRISPR a lot nowadays.
And you know, if you want to create things
if you want to, you know,
genetic create CRISPR constructs
or things that you can CRISPR things
in and out, you need to use some
a bit of PCR to engineer the CRISPR gene
to do exactly what you want to do.
Hopefully, all of this, you
know, made sense so far.
If anyone has any other questions,
Did it make sense?
And you guys can be honest,
cause I'm always happy to take feedback
and make things more
clear on how PCR works.
And you guys got to
see how it all happened
in sort of a cooking
method, like a cook show
where I can show things
pre done and post done.
Thank you.
And yeah, that's something
that we run all the time,
and if you guys ever work in a lab,
at least work in a Biology lab,
you definitely get the chance to play
with PCR or handle something like that.
Yeah. It's cool that you guys
get to see it in high school.
I actually never learned PCR
or learned about it until
I went to undergrad.
And then I actually did it myself.
So, yeah.
Any other questions about
PCR or applications?
There's so much you can do with it.
And like someone mentioned
about a really good
point, beat it, you know
beat the point
before I got to say it is that it's really
that we use this for,
for COVID-19 PCR testing.
And it's really important
for making. This is how
we keep our case numbers.
Or keep each other safe
is knowing the case number
the cases around us, right?
So yeah, there are all sorts
of applications for PCR and yeah.
And I'm glad you guys are more excited
about it then.
So, so excited about it because
as someone who does it all the time,
it feels like it's something
that you have to do
in the morning like a chore,
but there are days where it's exciting.
Like you see, or you see the gel
and you see how it works.
One more minute!
I'm going to turn on
the light one more time
and you guys might be able
to see how far it's gone.
Cause I think it turned off.
It automatically turns off to
like save energy and stuff.
- Hi everyone.
I'm Disan Davis with RockEDU.
I work with Donovan
and just wanted to jump in
while he was turning this back on,
to thank you all for participating
in the session today.
But to let you know that RockEDU
also has lots more
opportunities for you to engage
with Rockefeller University if
you liked what you saw today.
And so particularly we have
the Lab Jumpstart program
which is currently accepting
nominations and applications
for a research program that will start
in March after school
where you would learn basic techniques,
possibly just like PCR in more depth
than a lot more of things like that.
And then over the summer,
you'll spend seven weeks
working with scientists,
doing a research project.
And that'll all be from home.
The whole entire program,
this year is from home.
But we are still connecting
with scientists to make sure
that we can mail you kits
or set up software on your computer
so that you can do research
with scientists this year
even though so much of
our lives are virtual.
So please check that out.
The Jumpstart program
requires a nomination
but you can just ask your teacher
and he can help you out with that.
And we can get you more
information about that
and a whole bunch of other
things that we're doing.
So just wanted to thank you
all for checking this out
and you can go to our website
if you want to learn more.
I'll pop it right in the chat.
All right, Donovan back to you.
Cool, Yeah. Well that's
yeah. Super important.
Definitely check out Jumpstart if you can.
It's really fun.
I did it as an undergrad,
not through Jumpstart
but through different undergrad program.
And it's such an immersive experience
to get to at least, you
know, at a time working
in a lab or even just
going to do experiments
at home and like learn the process.
It's really, really insightful.
I have nothing else to
really talk about today.
I'm really glad you just got to see
see it's PCR and see how it works.
I can actually see now
within those 15, 20 minutes
all that stuff has ran out, right?
The top left.
I know it's a sideways, but
the top left is a ruler.
So I always need to have a ruler
to know how big a fragment is.
These are like known white known sizes
and in the bottom right it's
actually my, my experiment.
I need to take out that
fragment later today
after you guys finish up this class.
So, so yeah, this is exactly
- [Disan] Did it work Donovan?
- It did. It did.
I got exactly what I needed.
I can go back to doing more cloning.
So, thank God.
But yeah, I'm glad you guys got to see it
and are excited about it.
And you know, if you
guys want to run PCR's
you can use one of my PCR's.
(Donovan laughing loudly)
Cool.
Glad it was fun, virtually.
I wish I could, can
make it more interactive
or make it you know, make,
have you guys see it,
but we used to do it.
And this is a program that we used to do
like a standard run through.
There's something called
'a lab of experiences'
where guys actually came in to do PCR.
And we use like the DNA from your,
from your cheek cells.
We would swab your cheek cells
and look at mitochondria DNA basically.
(inaudible speaking)
I know, I know.
I wish you could see in real life too.
This is, this is as
much as this is as close
as I can get it to for you over zoom.
As virtual, as it gets.
Even I'm trying to even
live stream at you,
you see how it's moving
right there its live,
it's as live as it gets.
I don't normally even look
at it until the very end.
So this is, this is something.
Yeah.
- Thanks for inviting us guys.
You guys did a great job
and I don't know if you could
tell by posts in the chat,
but they were really excited
about the presentation
and I'm sure I'll get nothing
but positive feedback later on today.
- Bye guys, have a good holiday take care.
- [Student] Good bye.
- Take care.